[Music] it seems everyone is getting in the
Super Bowl Spirit including zoo animals all
over the country we're talking elephants
orangutans giraffes even a stingray all
making their prognostications for the big
game the animals usually are given a treat
representing both teams then Cokes to choose
one so here's the breakdown of the ones that
we found this week since we don't think that any
one species has any additional football insight
into any other wouldn't you know it as you can
see it is a tie so we go to the Maryland Zoo
and these miniature Mediterranean donkeys to have
us find out once and for all the wear Kansas City
Chiefs it's a tie why is it a tie because
they both they each one picked a different
team clearly the guy with the one guy
got him no but he got out first that's
why yeah you know he was surprised not a look
here's the replay I mean go to it instantly
he was out first he goes over to you yeah
and then another pick yeah it should have
been fast maybe that means the Chiefs are
up at half-time I don't know I don't know